c'est un passage obligé avant de se
rendre aux urnes se laver les mains en
guinée ni la crise politique née
l'épidémie de coronavirus n'auront fait
reculer le pouvoir qui a demandé aux
cinq millions d'électeurs de se déplacer
pour élire leurs députés et surtout se
prononcer sur le référendum
constitutionnel
un référendum contesté boycotté par
l'opposition qui dénonce une manoeuvre
du chef de l'état alpha condé pour se
maintenir au pouvoir et ainsi briguer un
troisième mandat la veille malgré les
erreurs qui ont secoué le pays le chef
de l'état qui a décidé d'une série de
mesures pour faire face à l'épidémie de
couronnes à virus s'est voulu rassurant
la communauté d'états de la cedeao nuit
africaine organisation internationale de
la francophonie ont fait des
recommandations à travers le respect qu
est également mise en cause sur le plan
sanitaire aussi le président guinéen
fait également preuve de prudence
deux cas de covile 19 ont été recensés
sur le territoire dont l'un a été guérie
de l'autre côté de la frontière
guinéenne en côte d'ivoire où une
dizaine de personnes sont touchées par
le court aux navires us les forces de
l'ordre patrouillent les écoles et les
frontières du pays ont été fermés tout
rassemblement de plus de 50 personnes
interdit non plus pas de sensibilisation
n'est ce pas d'urgence et donc pouvoir
prêter la maison qui sont jean-louis en
ouganda
les autorités doivent elles faire face à
un premier cas de coronavirus un homme
de 36 ans originaire de dubaï
arrivé samedi matin dans la capitale
ougandaise le ministère de la santé
voudrais informer le public que
l'ouganda a confirmé son premier cas de
coronavirus le kovy 19
le ministère de la santé rassure le
grand public sur le fait que toutes les
mesures ont été prises pour identifier
ce cas à l'aéroport l'isoler en temps
voulu
l'afrique subsaharienne est la région la
plus touchée si des seuils ont été
enregistrés au burkina faso au gabon sur
l'île maurice ou encore en république
démocratique du congo
la majeure partie des cas recensés sur
le continent sont des cas importés
d'europe d'après l'om est-ce qui a
enjoint ce mercredi les chefs d'état
africains à se préparer au pire